صالحه تخرجت من جامعه كابول قبل 35 عاما
في عهد الرئيس الاسبق نجيب الله تقول انها
وزميلاتها كنا يدرسن في فصول مشتركه مع
الفتيان في وقت كانت الحريه تسود الاجواء
التعليميه ان ذلك وخاصه زي الفتيات
الدراسات العليا كما كانت المراه تستطيع
ان تختار تخصصها في جميع المجالات المتاحه
دون ان يدعوائق
اما شقيقه صالحه فقد التحقت بجامعه كابول
بعد عامين من صالحه ولكنها لم تستطع
مواصله الدراسه جراء ظروف عسكريه تضيف ان
المراه الافغانيه قد ظلمت قديما وحديثا
بدرجات مختلفه
الاجتماعيه
فقد تم القضاء على عمليه دراستهن وتدريسهن
في البلد
التي تخرجت منها صالح اكبر واشهر جامعه في
افغانستان والتي تم تاسيسها سنه
1930 ميلاديه قدمت الالاف من الخريجات في
تخصصات مختلفه الى المجتمع الافغاني
المسيره الطويله في رحله تعليم الفتيات لن
تتوقفها فالمجتمع الى الافغاني وعلى الرغم
من الازمات المتلاحقه تظل رغبه الافغان
بمستقبل افضل يكون فيه التعليمه حجر
الزاويه عبد القادر العربيه كابول